appelle-moi
puis-je te demander quelque chose
auquel tu vas t'attendre [Musique] c'est qui tu étais quand tu travaillais
[Musique]
une fois que j'étais enfant, je pouvais toujours être
cet autre gars
[Musique]
Je veux dire c'est ce qu'il doit faire  hey
allez dans Julian ayez un siège détective de
quoi s'agit-il tu es un homme libre
[Musique]
les 15 dernières années de ma vie je pensais avoir
tué cette fille tu ne fais de mal à
personne c'était un tueur
envoie-moi dehors
ne peut pas le laisser te voir il va juste le refaire
ils sont toujours là-bas ce n'est pas fini
je pense que je veux retourner au travail
pourquoi pas
il voulait travailler
avec des
gens puissants
[Musique]
étrangers